hi Leute hier ist wieder eure
malwanne wie versprochen gibt es jetzt
mein kleines Halloween Special heute mit
dem sugar Sky also einem mexikanischen
Totenkopf der ist das Symbol vom Tag der
Toten also Mexico dia de los Muertos ich
kann kein mexikanisch kein Spanisch oh
mein Gott war das gerade peinlich okay
wir machen einfach
weiter und das ist eins der wichtigsten
mexikanischen Feiertage und weil das an
Halloween eigentlich ziemlich beliebt
ist wollte ich das auch mal ausprobieren
und wünsche euch ganz viel Spaß beim
zugucken und ich hoffe ich kann das
richtig erklären und jetzt laber ich
wieder viel zu viel und deshalb fangen
wir jetzt einfach an also ich bin ein
Fan davon wenn man sich so Sachen
zusammenwurstelt ich habe nicht jetzt
die professionellste Farbe ich habe so
ein zwei farbdinger die sind aber auch
schon mega alt ich hoffe dass ich keinus
Schlag davon kriegt es hat bis jetzt
immer gut funktioniert also wir werden
sehen und ansonsten einfach äh Stifte
und
und Lidschatten die ihr nicht habt
vielleicht hab hat sie eure Mutter eure
Schwester euer Bruder euer Vater
vielleicht auch man weiß ja immer nicht
was da so ne ist und
äh
so jetzt können wir anfangen wir fangen
an mit der Farbe mit der weißen die ist
bei mir schon echt alt bitte lieber Gott
lass mich nicht ein Ausschlag kriegen
ich werde
[Musik]
weiß was ich gerne zwischendurch tue ist
mal nachpudern weil damit verhindert ihr
dass ihr da am Ende so eine klebrige
Masse auf eurem Gesicht habt
dann bleibt auch alles auf seinem Platz
und jetzt umrande ich die Flächen die
ich später
[Musik]
ausmale
auch hier wieder pudern dann nehme ich
einfach mir das schwarze Puder und mal
alles nach damit das auch richtig fest
wird jetzt nimmt ihr wieder euren
Kajalstift und geht an die Feinheiten
[Musik]
ran
kommen wir nur zu dem spinnnetz auf der
Stirn seht ihr diesen
Mittelpunkt das fordert ein bisschen
Konzentration und wenn ihr das nicht so
gut hinkriegt dann macht ein bisschen
langsamer dann
läuft an diesem spinnnetz könnt ihr
erkennen dass ich kein Profi bin aber
das habe ich auch nie behauptet also
Hater g hate jetzt malen wir das
umgedrehte
Herz viel
Glück das Herz in der Mitte male ich
einfach mit einem Lipliner
aus so ich mal jetzt um die Augen herum
dafür nehme ich aus so einer Palette ich
nehme jetzt das Gel
wie gesagt wenn ihr bunten Lischatten
habt dann eignet es sich gut erstmal so
ein schönen Streifen um die Augen zu
[Musik]
malen und jetzt ma ich diese
Kringel als nächstes ich die die roten
hier so
drüber dann nehme ich noch mal mein
[Musik]
buuder so jetzt kommen kümmern wir uns
um die rosa am k Rose mal für
Anfänger die Rose wird jetzt hier so
Kind gemalt dafür mach einfach so
ein
halbherz noch ein halb
Herz noch ein halb Herz seht ihr
das nochen
K hab eine Rose aufings ist nicht schwer
n
so wirklich schön ist es jetzt nicht
geworden wir malen aber noch an dann
wird das noch was
dafür nehmen wir wieder unser buntes
Puder da seid ihr hallo ich nehm rosa
und mit dem rosa male ich jetzt einfach
die Flächen aus ich habe so Make-up
Stifte oder so Schminkstifte und mit den
male ich jetzt die grünen
Blätter also nicht viele
so wenn ihr das getan hab nimmt ihr
wieder Euren besten Freund den
Kajalstift und umrandet die und macht da
diese blätterartigen Adern rein Adern so
heißt
es
irgendwie ich will das noch mal
korrigieren über die Rose sprechen wir
jetzt nicht mehr ich habe einfach ein
dickes rosanes kin jetzt
das sieht jetzt cool aus war aber gar
nicht so cool gedacht ich habe eben
lilanen drauf gemacht dann habe ich mit
ein schwarzen Pinsel mir auf die Lippen
gemalt und dann ist alles verschmiert
und jetzt habe ich so ein rosanen
Lippenstift genommen und das ist wohl
die beste Kombi weil ich find das hat
irgendwie ein geilen Effekt so ein
bisschen und jetzt kommt endlich ein
bisschen Kajalstift in die Augen da
müsst ihr aber aufpassen dass er keine
Farben jetzt dran
kleben letzter Schritt nehm immer ein
bisschen gerne Blush
Rouge Zeug auf die Wangen Zeugs
und Puder auf den
Wangen ein bisschen
rosa und jetzt gehen wir für die Haare
und für den Haarschmuck ins Badezimmer
ich verarsche euch jetzt ein bisschen
und ma nur meine vorderen Haare lockig
weil hinten ist noch so viel Haar dass
das Ewigkeiten dauern würde bis man es
hinkriegt die ganzen Locken zu
machen ich glaube ich wäre ein sehr
schlechter
Beautykanal dumme Gesichter kann ich
machen und ich sehe auch immer auf
Instagram ihr hab ein Talent dafür
mir Screenshots zu schicken wo ich sehr
dumm drauf aussehe aber das macht mir
nichts ich stehe da
drüber okay so wenn ihr etwas wie locken
auf eurem Kopf habt dann kommt jetzt das
schönste
Teil ist das nicht schön ich finde das
ich habe das im Laden gesehen bei
CL CL also dieses mit dem C das ist so
lila und so der L der hat nur so
paarschmuck Zeugs und so und dann habe
das gesehen und hab mich darin
verliebt jetzt machen
in und sehen aus wie eine
sugarskull so Leute ich hoffe euch hat
so ein kleines Ernstes Tutorial auch
gefallen und wenn ja dann gibt mir ein
Daumen nach oben und Abonniert mich hier
unten wenn ihr noch mehr sehen wollt
links und rechts von mir sind zwei
Videos wenn euch was davon interessiert
klickt es an schaut es euch an und wir
sehen un beim nächsten Mal und ich
wünsche euch schöne Halloween wenn ihr
die feiert und wenn nicht dann nicht
aber ich rate euch feiert es es ist cool